et maintenant la question du port des
signes religieux ostensibles appliquées
à l'université car je vous rappelle que
la nouvelle loi ne concerne que les
écoles les collèges les lycées pas la
fac
d'où l'initiative des présidents
d'université qui viennent de se réunir
pour rédiger un petit guide un guide
pratique sur laïcité et enseignement
supérieur
un petit livre qui évidemment n'a pas
force de loi nabila taboury isabelle
steiss voile qipao grande croix à
l'université il est interdit de les
interdire
car la loi sur la laïcité ne s'applique
pas la raison est simple les étudiants
sont adultes malgré cela la fac n'est
pas à l'abri d'incidents et
revendications communautaires aux
religieuses se sont multipliés ces
dernières années le fait par exemple de
récuser une enseignante qui interroge un
étudiant lors d'un examen au motif que l
est de sexe féminin qui a perturbé
évidemment le bon déroulement des
activités pédagogiques le fait par
exemple de ne pas accepter qu'il y ait
une approche scientifique des textes
sacrés ne peut pas n'est pas acceptable
dans l'université pour aider les
présidents d'université souvent démunis
face à ce genre de revendications
un guide laïcité vient d'être publié
solutions juridiques pour régler les
incidents des textes de loi le livret se
veut avant tout pédagogique
ces incidents souvent réglés dans la
discrétion créé malgré tout des tensions
au sein des universités
et c'est justement ce malaise que le
guide voudrait dissiper